[MUSIC]
Well, thank you very much and
good morning, everyone.
>> Good morning.
>> Good morning and welcome back to
Stanford and those of you online,
don't you wish you were here?
>> [LAUGH]
>> So we wish you were here too but
we understand somebody has to work.
So [LAUGH]
it's great to
see a lot of old friends and
welcome you back.
I quite enjoy speaking with
the alums because in contrast
to what I do in my regular classes I don't
have to try to explain history as much.
And so, actually I'm serious.
It's much easier because if you're talking
on where great firms and where great
leaders come from, there's been a lot
of rewriting of history over the years.
And so there's a little bit of grandpa
explaining to the MBAs what really
happened at certain times and so
we'll tell a few of those stories.
One thing I would like to say for you,
though, is that any time you want to ask
a question, throw up your hand, and
come out, or just come up to the mic.
And I'll just stop and
go ahead and ask the question.
So I've structured my remarks to
maybe raise a few ideas that you
might find interesting but also to allow
for time for you to ask questions.
So you can ask questions any time
by coming up to the microphone,
and if you raise your hand,
wave at me and make sure I see.
So let's start with an observation
that does come out of the research,
but also just out of my own experience,
and probably out of your experience.
We are really bad at predicting.
But we are really good at
retrospectively rationalizing.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
I mean that not to be cynical,
I am big on retrospective rationalization.
And I think it's an important
part of leadership,
because you do have to make sense
out of why people come to work.
And in that sense leaders are always
looking back at things that have
happened and
explaining to people why it makes sense.
But when you look at the track record,
when you combine our talent at
retrospective rationalization with
our incredible inability to predict.
So I remember in the classroom.
It was 1993 and I was doing a case study
of a software company
that had made a product
that could manipulate
photographic images digitally but
on a low end personal
computer pretty efficiently.
And the entrepreneur was from France.
He and
his team had come over from Toulouse,
decided they'd be here in Silicon Valley.
And they had set up,
his name was Bruno De Leon,
some of you may remember Bruno,
a real whiz kid in software.
And had come up with tremendous
innovation that is still there In your
digital technology that you carry around.
And, we had the normal class session
where we do the case study and
the students are asking questions and
we're talking.
And then at some point,
with his amazing French accent,
I wish I could talk like that.
He starts to say, that,
now remember what year this is, 1993.
The first browsers are just being created.
We're not talking about the World Wide Web
yet, there's some discussion of it.
Of course, the Internet and BITNET and
other such networks already existed for
scientists and academics, but
the world's about to change.
And he says, I envision a world
where in just a couple of years
everyone's carrying around small
computers with the main purpose
being to trade photographs back and
forth with each other.
Okay, now the best part of this,
and I have it on film, okay,
is the look on my, so
I'm standing kind of off to the side.
You know how they've got
the visitor there, and
he's sort of going on like this.
And the students are looking at him, and
they're looking at me rolling their eyes,
okay.
Now maybe some of you are in that
class and so [LAUGH] at the end of
the term when the professor gets
graded by the students right?
So I'm looking through and well,
Barnett's okay on this and Barnett's.
But get rid of this De Leon guy, and
get a real business in here, because
this guy's a whack job, he's a crazy.
That's the problem.
When we do predict the future,
nobody believes it, nobody believes it.
Nobody believes it, and I remember sort of
giving lectures on industrial evolution.
And a lot of the things we talked
about nowadays with disruption,
we were talking about it of
course even back in the 90s.
And by about 96,
I remember teaching the strategy, 95.
I was teaching the strategy
core course and
one of the MBAs was sitting
right in the front center.
She raises her hand.
I'm going on about how industries change
and new firms come in and old firms die.
And she says Professor Barnett.
Now you have to realize that at that
time I had a lot more, well just,
hair and red in my beard and everything.
But nonetheless,
I was an ancient man to her and she said,
Professor Barnett, this sounds
like a theory of the olden days.
[LAUGH] My gosh It's great,
I love teaching,
I just love teaching here really.
When everyone in class feels like they
are the embodiment of human evolution up
to this moment.
>> [LAUGH] I mean it's kind of [LAUGH].
But that's okay, they're only outdone by,
yeah, when it comes to arrogance.
So, it's [LAUGH], so we're all in the
same, [LAUGH] this is the pot calling the.
So, yeah, I sort of looked at her and
said well, what do you mean?
[LAUGH] And she says, well now,
everything's changed, everything's stable.
We have Microsoft.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's easy to forget that we thought
we had finally reached equilibrium, these
theories you've learned about equilibrium.
Everything goes to equilibrium this and
equilibrium that, and equilibrium
price and equilibrium quantity.
And steady state technology and
sustainable advance.
I don't know what all this stable
states are, I haven't seen them yet.
I study growth and failure.
I've been here since 91.
Talk about being at the right place and
the right time,
there's no stability that I can find.
But at the time, it seemed that way
because we had a giant firm that had
by then probably, I don't know, 90,
95% of the desktop organized for us.
And things seemed to that bright, young
woman as now we're all really stable.
And if I would have told her, well,
I'll tell you what I told her.
I said, look, I don't know what's going to
happen that's going to make
us forget about Microsoft.
But whatever it is,
it's going to be bodacious.
And the whole class looks at me like,
that's all you got?
You get this bright question and
all you can use is an adjective?
The trouble is back to
predicting the future.
If I could have gone forward, I had
gotten in that car that takes you to and
looked at the world then gone back and
said.
You're not going to believe it,
it's going to be this college dorm project
where that guy in 93,
he appears to have been right.
But really just trading pictures of my
grandson back and forth with everyone.
Even if we could predict the future,
we wouldn't believe it.
This is a problem,
if you're a business school professor.
Seriously, because if you think about it,
if I'm in your shoes,
as an alumnus or
if you think of the current students.
They want to go out into the world and
be great and
they want to understand that process.
And part of becoming
great is coming here and
meeting each other and
becoming part of that network.
And there's just that incredible life and
everything else that goes with it.
But from a business school professor's
perspective I want us to be able to
give you some tools that will help you
increase your chances of being great.
But this is a world where we have proven
ourselves to be very bad at predicting
which is a quandary if you're me and
my colleagues like me.
Well, of course we've known about
this quandary for some time and
we could all tell stories of companies
that discover their greatness.
You may remember Apple computer
when it was a computer company, if we
just look at the 2000 to 2016 period.
Nevermind everything that went on before,
a lot of folks in here,
we can talk about that,
that was also fascinating.
But if you go just back to the year 2000,
Steve Jobs was being rehabilitated.
He had just came back to Apple,
had been fired several years before.
On the East Coast,
there's a business school, which in 1996,
featured Steve Jobs as
the example of how not to lead.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It was their first case study,
the Donna Dubinsky case.
He fired Donna because she thought and
talked at the same time, she leaned in.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] So
the downside of leading in.
And of course she's amazing as a leader,
went on to be a very successful
entrepreneur, now venture capitalist.
And so, that particular
leadership development program,
which is a very good program.
Led off with the Donna Dubinsky case,
depicting, that's not how to be a leader.
I can tell you that by about 2004,
when I would give lectures like
this anywhere in the world,
I often ask the question, who's a great
leader, to sort of warm up the crowd.
And depending on where I am,
you get really interesting answers,
see in Zagreb,
the answer was Genghis Khan.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay, in Peoria, it was Jesus Christ.
The prophet Mohammed was raised
as a possible candidate for
a great leader in Dubai.
I could go down the list
in Moscow you can guess.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] So
that was Putin but that was close.
[LAUGH] So, but they always say
Steve Jobs, they always say Steve Jobs.
So you go from being how not to
lead in 95, 96, to being ranked,
eight years later, alongside Jesus Christ,
the prophet Mohammed.
And Genghis Khan, as one of the great
leaders to have ever existed in human
history, we are so bad at predicting.
>> [LAUGH]
>> We are so
good at retrospectively rationalizing.
And how easily we forget, and
I think you can relate with me on this,
because you remember some of these times.
So iTunes introduced in 2001,
with no iPad, and no store.
It was a jukebox,
where the strategy was to make
the desktop computer more valuable.
So that maybe Apple could
pull out of its 3% of
market share doldrums versus
the Windows-based Intel Windows PCs.
That was actually
the strategy at the time.
Couple of years later,
the store is introduced, and
Apple is shocked by the 10
million downloads of songs.
They suddenly find out they're selling
more music than they are computers
in 2003 and the strategy begins to change.
Do you remember the hell
freezes over announcement?
Remember the strategy was to have
the Macintosh beat the PC, on
the desktop but suddenly they're selling
more music than they are computers.
And that's just among
people with a Macintosh,
because iTunes only functioned at
that time on an Apple computer.
So Steve Jobs stepped out and
put up a big, the black outfit, and
the big screen with the, and
it said hell freezes over.
Anybody remember what they did?
They released iTunes on Windows, that's
right, they released iTunes on Windows.
And immediately, within two months,
there were another 15 million downloads,
and they completely shifted the strategy.
Let's not worry about, in fact,
within a couple of years,
they would drop the name computer from
their name, they become a music company.
It's often the case that we discover
greatness, what's interesting,
if they had stayed to plan,
that wouldn't have happened.
If they had stayed to plan,
that wouldn't have happened, of course,
we all have plans.
But the interesting thing on the
leadership side was the ability of their
leadership not to predict the future but
to create a system that
discovers that future.
And of course I raise Apple
as an example of that but
there are plenty of other examples,
I would guess that right now.
If we went around this room,
we would have dozens and dozens and
dozens of examples of your own companies,
or
companies you've been with in your
careers, that have discovered greatness.
Because in the years, since
about 1985 plenty of research has been
done to trace the histories of firms and
it looks like it is not the exception
to see the likes of an Apple.
Of course Apple was
possibly the most valuable
company in the world right
now is quite exceptional but
that story of discovering greatness
is the rule, not the exception.
Let's talk about Semex we're
in the theater that is
endowed by Semex and so
we're required to talk about Semex.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Mr Zambrano, so no, seriously though.
So I love the Cemex
case because everybody,
when they hear these discovery stories,
Airbnb.
It starts out with three techies and
they lose a roommate and
if you're a techie whenever you have
a need, you write a webpage, right?
So if you're hungry, you write a webpage,
you're lonely, you write a webpage.
They lost a roommate,
let's write a webpage.
Sure enough, people start landing on it.
They want to rent the couch and gosh,
we can make this a business and then they
want to make it so that events like South
by Southwest or they were politicos.
So around 2007, 2008 at
the Democratic National Convention,
the first of the Obama Conventions,
they said
we'll use this website to help people find
a place when they go to the convention.
It really didn't work very well for
event organizing.
It turns out people plan when they go
to conventions and they get a room.
>> [LAUGH]
>> They don't just show up in town,
my god, a room.
Right?
[LAUGH] They'll make a webpage.
[LAUGH]
And one of the big problems they
had making it work were all these people
were trying to use the website just to
rent from each other and they were trying
to figure out how could we stop this?
[LAUGH] Don't they
understand our strategy?
We're trying to do event.
If they had succeeded in their plan,
they would have been worth millions.
[LAUGH]
Okay,
that reaction tells me you have some
sense of what Airbnb is worth now.
I don't know, is it $30 billion?
I don't know what the number is now,
more than Marriott.
At some point, they said, wait a minute,
this bothersome problem we have of all
these people trying to use the website.
[LAUGH] We're trying to
improve the desktop.
Wait a minute,
we're selling how much music?
This discovery process goes
on in company after company.
And a lot of people think
it's only tech companies.
It happened at CEMEX.
And some of you will remember this because
we have an age old Cemex case I still keep
in the curriculum because I love it.
People think I'm required to teach it but
I'm not, I love it.
Mr. Zambrano Sr.,
decades ago, had acquired
a couple of companies in Spain.
The intent, the strategy was to smooth
out the business cycle for CEMEX.
Maybe because cement is
very based on construction,
very cyclical, high fixed cost business.
You're operating only in Mexico, then
you'll really be holding to that business
cycle and he thought,
if we were in multiple countries,
we would have counter cyclical
movement of the business cycle.
And that was especially difficult at
the time because now we're a little bit
better with financial hedging for
dealing with that kind of cyclicality.
But finance markets had a little more
trouble with that at the time CEMEX as
one of the Mexican grupos at the time had
also more trouble accessing some of
those international finance markets.
They get over to Spain to do
the typical post merger integration,
they send over their team of managers and
engineers trained at Monterey Tech.
These folks are wiz kids when it comes
to state of the art manufacturing,
operations, logistics, supply chains,
they put in truck tracking,
they clean up the accounting systems.
They dramatically improve the performance
of the Spanish facilities.
It turns out, most cement companies
in the world, decades ago,
were sleepy monopolies because of the
nature of cement and transportation costs,
they're typically the only game in town,
often government sponsored and so forth.
CEMEX was vastly more efficient
because of the fact that they hire so
much out of Monterey Tech.
And at that point,
Zambrano says wait a minute, if we're that
good that we can dramatically improve the
performance of those Spanish acquisitions,
let's write up a set of routines on that,
and now lets do it to ourselves.
It's one of the few firms I
know that have the courage
to post-merger integrate themselves.
because we all like to post-merger
integrate other people, and
some of you have done that, or
been on the receiving end of it.
But this company said, look,
if we can do it to them,
we've got plants and
facilities we acquired around Mexico, so
they dramatically improved
their own performance.
Then as many of you know,
went on a very long run of
acquisitions where they would go in,
do post-merger integration, dramatically
improve the efficiency of operations.
The world's finance markets
fall in love with them.
What becomes their strategy
was discovered and
that's the cement industry,
so it's not only in tech.
You see the discovery of why you're
great even in the cement industry.
You shop at Trader Joe's,
you know when they started?
All you people don't shop at Trader Joe's?
because I know there's more
wine drinkers out there than,
you're smiling if nothing else,
you must be.
They started out selling cigarettes and
ammunition.
[LAUGH]
>> Seriously, I knew Joe Coulombe,
I had case studies on it, it's how they
started, just went through an evolution.
Now they're selling boutique honey and
names of cheese I can't pronounce.
By the way, don't go there now looking for
cigarettes and ammunition.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You'd be arrested for the cigarettes.
The ammunition would be okay.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's America.
>> Sorry, I digress.
[LAUGH] So it's interesting, plenty of
non technology firms go through it too.
Now here's the point though that makes
business school professors happy
about this.
It isn't just dumb luck If you
tell enough of these stories,
then people start thinking, what
Barnett's getting at is it's a crapshoot.
It turns out some people tend to get
consistently more lucky than others.
At some point, it stops being luck, when
some people are having all the luck, and
some people aren't.
When some companies are repeatedly
going through a discovery process, and
some are not.
And that's because the discovery process,
while it is not good at predicting
the outcome, does follow a pattern.
It always follows the same pattern,
regardless of where you see it happen,
three things always happen
in the discovery process.
If we understand these three things that
happened in the discovery process, we as
leaders can make it more likely that our
own company get lucky more than it should.
I want to talk about those three things.
It's fun to tell stories
about companies that
discovered something much greater
than they had planned to do.
But it's a lot more fun to drill down and
think about what are those three
underlying processes that always seem to
go on when companies
are good at discovery.
I want to talk about that, but
if people have questions,
sometimes this is a nice time.
We're kind of into the storytelling,
and now you're all sitting and
you've had your coffee, so
if there's questions, you can.
That's fine, I'll just keep talking.
You want to know the three things.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] And
they're in a book that I wrote.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] No,
actually I did write a book.
But you should not buy my book.
I gotta tell you, do not buy my book.
My wife, God love, Yvette and
I have been together for 35 years, and so
She read my book and described it as
having been written not to be read.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Now I know that sounds like the snarky
wife comment, maybe it is a snarky wife
comment, I kind of took a sober look at
that book, once I kind of was clear from
it and realized she was absolutely right.
That book is filled with econometrics, and
it's meant to prove a point to
my colleagues, statistically.
So you really don't want to buy the book.
But it did make me think that I have to
find a way to give the ideas that were in
the book and in other things that I have
written a more accessible presentation.
And so I will tell you about my website,
>> [LAUGH]
>> But it's free.
But the reason I like people to go on my
website is I love to get the comments
back and it helps me, basically what I do
now is I put all my teaching notes online.
I tried to do it a few years ago, and
it freaked out the intellectual property
people here, because they were all on
sort of Stanford letterhead and
I was just giving them away.
All right, so I had to rewrite everything
on a blog, but they're my teaching notes.
So they're available
everywhere except China.
[LAUGH]
Which is I go over there and
lecture all the time,
I'm not quite sure why.
Anyway, so it's just my name
Barnett Talks, because I do.
And then all my teaching
notes are on there.
If you like it spoon fed,
you can get it that way too.
And then when I make mistakes or
whatever else and
people correct me and that's, so
I'm being a little selfish with that, but
at least the ideas are free there so
I put my ideas there.
But I will tell you,
let's talk about those three things, okay?
Let's talk about those three things.
And the first thing we need to talk
about comes down to what happens
when you have a good idea,
an innovative idea.
Now, when you have an innovative idea
does everybody have to agree with
your idea for it to be a good one?
No, of course not.
In fact, it's obviously a rhetorical
question, right, you can see why.
If nothing else, you wouldn't come
to a Stanford event and expect, no,
I only want to think about something
if everyone, It's kind of being here,
it's kind of When you have an innovative
idea, what's the first thing you do?
You tell somebody, exactly.
You tell somebody.
What if they don't like it,
what do you do?
You tell somebody else, absolutely.
There's plenty of research on this,
that's exactly what happens.
Hopefully, you tell somebody else,
hopefully,
who hasn't talked to the first
person you told because.
It's interesting though,
because less than 60 seconds ago you
told me it really didn't matter,
but it appears to matter a lot.
If we can have a good idea regardless of
whether everybody's agreeing with us why
are we trying to find people who
agree with us, what's going on?
What is it about having, why are we
feeling compelled to ask other people
if we think our innovative idea could be
right, even if they don't agree with us?
What's going on?
Okay, so we're looking for validation.
>> We want to execute the plan.
>> We want to be able to execute it,
right?
So we might want validation, but
the other side is we might
want to make sure we could do.
So if they disagree it's not so
much that we think we're wrong,
we just realized we got a bit of
a wall to get past to get it, right?
We've got to line our ducks up,
which is an interesting.
In fact,
let's play with this idea a little bit.
Let's play with this idea a little bit.
When you have an innovative idea,
You might be right, can you see that?
Okay.
But you might be wrong.
You might be wrong.
This isn't like good, bad.
It's like correct, incorrect.
Okay.
[LAUGH] You might be right but
you might be wrong and you know it.
If you think about it when
it comes to innovation,
if you know you're right,
it's probably not an innovative idea.
Right if you gotta kind of.
So when you ask other people and they're
agreeing with you you'd like to know
whether it's giving you a clue about
whether you're right or wrong,
the trouble is you don't know,
maybe they don't know either.
And so you know in your heart when
you ask other people that if they're
agreeing with you all it's really telling
you is that the idea is consensus.
That's all it's really telling you.
And if you're getting pushback
all it's really telling
you is that it's a non-consensus idea.
Whether it's right or wrong, one thing for
sure I'm getting a lot of pushback.
This is a non-consensus idea.
And the problem with discovering greatness
is that all four of those are possible and
we know it.
We know that every time we're
thinking of something innovative,
we know that that's the case.
So let's work through those possibilities.
And the best way to structure it
is to start with the assumption
that you're right.
Now you can't know you're right and
have it be innovative.
But let's assume somehow you
did know that you are right.
So if you knew you were right,
where would you rather be?
What's the argument?
So I've heard both coming up.
So what's the argument for consensus?
Okay, everybody agrees with you so
we're back to the execution point.
We're definitely going to
be able to execute this.
What's the argument for non-consensus?
Okay we can make it better
through the dialectic.
Okay.
Okay, yeah.
>> You'll certainly be out in front.
Right.
You're going to be out in front.
But it's going to be hard to execute,
we gotta give the execution people this.
Now, you're the execution guy.
For the rest of the day you're like Mr.
Execution, which can be good.
So this is the way I think of it,
this is going to be hard to execute,
but if you do execute,
you can tell I'm not a finance professor,
there would be Greek letter here,
instead the symbol I'm going to use is.
>> [LAUGH]
>> A strategy professor,
this is a great place to be,
right, but this is Irwin Jacobs.
Irwin Jacobs and
his fellow scientist Viterbi
started Qualcomm based on CDMA technology,
a wireless technology that was
very controversial and
a very non-consensus idea.
DARPA had given up on CDMA,
they thought that It was so complicated,
they created it with,
sponsored the research that created
Code Division Multiple Access Technology,
and they wanted it to
help encode messages that the Soviet Union
could then not intercept.
So fun to be able to talk to a crowd who
understands what the Soviet Union is,
because I normally then have to explain-
>> [LAUGH]
>> That there was this empire,
it was a giant empire, it's true,
it actually existed, and then [LAUGH], but
it's very, and then they'll say,
you're talking about Russia, well now.
So, they so gave up, and was so
complicated they put it
out in a public domain.
And they said, even the Russians
can't figure this out, I mean,
it's just you know.
We'll just put it out there,
and so very non-consensus,
banned in Europe because of it,
banned in Europe.
Because they wanted TDMA only for GSM.
Create a real problem when
the smartphone comes along,
since CDMA was a lot
better at carrying data.
And we're so bad at predicting.
But we're very good at
retrospectively rationalizing it.
So,they own a lot of IP at Qualcomm,
and that leads to this outcome.
Because when you're the only game,
when you're the only one who thinks you're
right, then you might end up owning
a lot of the IP, because nobody else
is even going to do research on it.
Now here you can execute, the trouble
is everybody is executing on it.
Right, which from a strategic perspective,
it's not a bad thing,
but we're all doing it.
So this you can execute,
this is going to be hard to execute, but
if you can, the payoff is now.
What if you're wrong,
where do you want to be if you're wrong?
Absolutely, consensus, no big story,
[LAUGH] it's just humans, when
they're wrong do not want to be alone.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Right.
It's as simple as that.
It's just as simple as that,
I mean, [LAUGH] your kid asks you.
My wife and I have six kids, so I've had
this questions come up a number of times,
or the,
the statement come up a number of times.
Your kid comes home and says, Dad,
this is the latest rendering of it.
Everybody at school-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah, never a good start to any
conversation.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> Everybody at school had a lot of
trouble on the history test.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> Is your daughter suddenly concerned
about the state of education in Palo Alto?
[LAUGH]
>> It's kind of [LAUGH].
You know she's calibrating you.
Right, she's trying to get you over here,
because then we can talk about,
you know, and then it's not so bad.
Okay I lost money in 2000, but
we all lost money in 2000.
So for me it was Webvan.
I don't know what yours was, but you know.
This guy.
He's a fool.
This guy is a fool.
We told him he was wrong.
He did it anyway.
And he's wrong.
And the problem with
discovering great business.
And the number one problem
with the discovery process,
is that humans fear being a fool,
much more than they hope to be a genius.
And a result, they're quiet
about their non-consensus ideas.
They're asking people,
they realize it's non- consensus.
And in fact, you should ask yourself this,
your people in your organization,
are they quiet about their non-consensus
ideas, for fear they might be seen a fool?
And if so,
what does that say about your leadership?
Because some places are safer than others,
when it comes to non-consensus behavior.
Some people, this is a career ender,
some places, this is a career ender.
And if this is a career ender,
you're never going to hear that.
This brings up the first property of
all systems that discover greatness.
And that is, they are systems
that generate variability.
They generate variability.
Now notice I didn't say
they generate greatness.
I said they generate variability, and
let me explain why I put it that way.
You can tell I'm an old chalkboard guy.
If you think about the innovative process.
All innovative processes,
including companies,
are producing innovations.
Now an innovation isn't a good thing.
It just means it's a new thing.
It might be amazing, it might be foolish.
And the point on innovation is,
we don't know until we try
the difference between folly and genius.
Remember the stories of
Bruno Deleon in 1993,
the end of industrial revolution in 1995.
And how we're so bad a predicting.
With that lesson in mind.
New ideas, new possibilities come along.
They might be foolish.
They might be genius.
The year that Google was found, I don't
know what the distribution looks like.
You know, that's optimistic.
Maybe the distribution is that there's
a lot more foolishness out there.
I don't know what
the distribution looks like.
The year that Google was founded,
if you look in the archived press,
at the time everybody knew that
search was not a business.
We had seen the failure of AltaVista,
and Excite, and
Lycos, and
you name your favorite dead search engine.
And so there was a lot of talk that,
well search is necessary,
maybe it's a public utility.
You know, we'll have PGNS, all right?
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] Or PGNES, I don't know.
Now, my marketing colleagues
tell me that search is clearly,
the most valuable business model
in the history of humankind.
>> [LAUGH]
>> We are so bad at predicting.
And we are so
good at retrospectively rationalizing.
And so at the time,
we don't know what's here or what's here.
And this is generally true,
by the way, this is generally true,
I mean it plagues all attempts
to increase innovation.
It plagues all attempts
And in companies you'll often see
a desire to have more innovation,
but only to have smart innovation.
Now, can we really get away with that?
Yes, I don't think we can either.
The city state of Singapore, one of
the great miracle economies of the world,
has a lot of different programs,
to try to improve it's economy.
It's an amazing place.
Some of you may have spent time in
Singapore, may be from Singapore.
But they actually tried to do this, and
their experiment is worth thinking about.
They noticed that Singapore
was very efficient, but
wasn't being innovative enough, and
a few years ago had one of their campaigns
focus on increasing spontaneity.
So they wanted to bring people in from
the arts, and music, and create more of a,
I guess a Greenwich Village
feel to Singapore.
Now the trouble with being a street
musician in Singapore [LAUGH]
This is, I'm remembering my youth.
All my college and
graduate school was at Berkeley.
Sometime you want to take a field
trip up but not all together.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] They'll know if they get
somebody, the Dean out in front,
you'll all go up.
But go just independently up to Berkley
and check out the street musicians.
It's not a pretty sight.
When the street musicians
started showing up in Singapore,
they have a cleanliness campaign.
They took them aside,
issued them a poncho and a playlist.
They could play Peter,
Paul and Mary lyrics.
>> [LAUGH]
>> This is true.
This is actually what happened.
I think Puff the Magic Dragon had
a meaning that was not understood.
We understood it in Berkeley,
I can tell you.
If you see what's going on,
they say we want innovation, but
we've been to Berkeley.
So they say, what we're going to have
is we're going to have innovation, but
we're not going to have any of this.
We're not going to have any of this.
That's much better.
Uh-oh.
My gosh.
What happened?
You see what happens is when we try
to control the innovation process and
have smart innovation and get rid of all
that, we think we're pushing up the mean.
What we're doing is we're
pushing down the variance.
When we think we're managing up the mean,
we're actually managing down the variance.
Because by virtue of
getting rid of foolishness,
what we're actually getting rid
of is non-consensus behavior.
Because remember, we don't know
the difference between genius and
folly before the fact.
All we know before the fact is
the difference between consensus and
non-consensus behavior.
Bob Dylan can't sing.
I think he just won the Nobel Prize.
We'll cut him some slack on his ability
to hit every note in the scale.
I'm sure we would have cleaned him out.
You see what I'm getting at here?
There's even a historian of science who
has looked at all of the Albert Einstein's
work and
found actually just arithmetic errors.
I tell you what,
if you can come up with a general theory,
we'll cut you some slack
on your arithmetic.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And that's the idea, that in the search
for genius, if you want genius, look for
systems that create foolishness.
If you find a system that's
creating foolishness,
there might be a chance of genius.
If you're finding a system that
never does anything foolish,
there's no way you're getting genius.
So that's the first property of these
systems, if you want you organization
to discover greatness,
it has to do something different.
Not only different it has to do something
different that is non-consensus.
Start thinking about
business plan competitions.
The consensus pick?
Not genius.
In fact, what I want to see in a business
plan competition is the plan that
generates the biggest argument,
the future Irwin Jacobs.
You see where I'm going with that.
You've got to manage for variance.
Now managing for variance is something
you can do in some companies,
you can't do for others.
With being an ancient professor,
you get more phone calls to go
talk to people and companies.
I get calls all the time from people who
should really be behaving predictably and
they say,
we want some of this innovation stuff.
I said, no, you really don't.
You do not want me to
come talk to your people.
I was called recently by an organization
on the other side of the world that runs
nuclear power plants.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah, you don't want me near them.
I want you to do it so predictably.
I want you to be Mr. Consensus.
The person who flies my airplane,
I want them to take off and
land the exact same way every time.
There's plenty of context where I don't
want experimentation and foolishness.
And I'm not going to kid myself and
say that I'm only going to
have smart innovation.
I'm going to say that a system has
to create variance, in order to.
So that's the biggest job.
Job one, variability.
If your system creates variation, you
have a chance of discovering greatness.
The second point is you have
to select from that variation.
And that's what all those little
stories were about Airbnb, and SAMx,
and Apple and
you name your favorite organization,
Trader Joe, your favorite organization
that discovered its greatness.
Leadership saw the possibility and
was able to select that
new possibility and
turn it into a strategy and
it's interesting.
If Apple had stayed with its strategy,
it would have been a computer company,
it probably would be history.
Certainly, wouldn't be the most
valuable company on Earth.
Airbnb same thing, would have been worth
a few million if they would have nailed it
on event lodging organizing and so forth.
Often what we discover in
the process of creating variation
has much more potential than whatever
it was we were planning to begin with.
And that process of selection
is typically iterative, or
we start with our strategy,
try to see how it works in
the market and then update our
strategy on this iterative way.
If we see strategy less as a planning
process and more as a discovery process,
now we have a chance of turning that
variability coming from our people,
those new ideas into reality.
The third part is retention or
growth, where we retain the ideas
that work best and we grow them.
And that's a tough part because if this
is over time and that's performance,
everybody knows when you change strategy,
what happens to your performance?
Goes down.
It takes a while to get a great
strategy's performance up.
The performances going to go up,
only after we survive the J curve.
How are we going to get through that
decline in performance as we're going in
a new direction?
We have to be able to get our people to
understand the logic of that new strategy
and that's leadership looking forward.
We connect the dots looking backwards.
That's the discovery process right here.
We connect the dots looking
backwards as Steve Job said in his,
I guess it was 2008,
his commencement address here.
He said, you can only connect
the dots looking backwards.
Looking forward, you have to believe
that the dots are going to connect.
Leadership has to give its people the
logic that has them believe that that's
possible.
You see where great leaders come from.
Great leaders are people who understand
that it is not their job to know
the future.
It is their job to create a system
that discovers that future.
In leading that system,
leaders perform two functions.
Looking back,
they retrospectively rationalize.
They make sense out of why your
people are doing what they're doing.
Looking forward,
They turn that into a logic, a strategy,
that helps their people survive the tough
times, when they try to change the world.
because changing the world is difficult,
and it takes time, but
when you persist,
you create something great.
Where else have you heard variation,
selection and retention?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> It's the Theory of Evolution.
Economies evolve just like the biosphere.
The difference is that,
in this process, we play a role.
It isn't blind variation.
It's variation among humans,
guided by leaders,
in some cases who make non
consensus behavior seem criminal.
And in other cases, who encourage that.
It's selection, but
selection mediated by leaders,
who create systems that try and learn.
Some organizations that learning,
because it's fraught with failure,
damns people's careers.
In other organizations,
that learning is seen as constructive.
And it's retention in the form of growth,
which in some organizations is only safe
if you can turn over a result
in the next week or quarter.
And don't blame the public markets.
Always look to leadership.
Because the public markets,
like any capital market,
have to be persuaded,
that that logic makes sense.
To believe long enough to get you there.
So whenever you see yourself pointing at
someone else, turn that finger back, and
ask yourself as a leader,
what role do you play in this process?
Are you increasing your organization's
chances of becoming great?
Because it isn't random luck.
It's all about great leadership.
So with that we have five minutes.
Any questions?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Okay,
the question was,
why was I blocked from China.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm not blocked from China.
So I go to China freely.
Well, not freely, I got to get a visa and
do the whole thing.
But it's just, you can't,
I'm not really sure why, I don't think I
said anything too outlandish, but
you can't reach my blog from China.
So yeah, no I wish there was a great
really interesting story where I had to,
like with Tom Cruise getting in a jet,
and escaping.
But it was just really,
[LAUGH] they just don't like my ideas.
>> Given your lecture, can you give us
some good questions to ask at the next
lecture on the 2016 Presidential Election?
>> [LAUGH]
[APPLAUSE]
>> [LAUGH] Yeah.
It's amazing.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> No, I'm not going to say anything, so.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> We're just going to let somebody ask
another question.
[LAUGH] So because your going to have
a whole talk on that with people who,
okay looks like we had a question coming
up here, and then I'll come to you.
Go ahead.
>> Question about measurement
in this whole process.
>> Yes.
>> A lot of these company examples,
you said they were measuring things,
and they realized then to shift past.
>> Yes.
>> But measurement always has a bias,
right, it focuses you on something.
So if you could just talk about
how that relates to all this.
>> Sure, sure, that's a great question.
So folks who are really familiar
with this part of the process,
understand that it's become a science or
pseudo-science these days,
where you look at
the feedback from testing.
You try to fail fast and cheap.
You look at the feedback from testing, and
then update on the basis of that feedback.
And those of you who study the engineering
of searching for optimized, sort of local
search, and in iterative optimization,
if those terms are appealing to you.
You know that this kind of measurement
suffers from a variety of problems that
often are talked about as bias.
So probably the biggest problem is
that it keeps you extremely focused
on short-term results.
So if you look here, if we're doing
AB testing of our new idea here,
we're going to pivot.
People love pivoting these days,
you gotta just go have a glass of
wine on University Avenue, and
listen to the young people talk, and
they all say the word pivot all the time.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And so,
the recipe is that you try something,
it doesn't work, you pivot, you're rich.
That's kind of the recipe.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
the problem is that great firms,
if they pivot here, they never get there.
And so, you do want to pivot,
if the very logic that
you think is true here,
is failing it's test.
But, if all you're doing is just looking
at a result, without thinking through
the logic of the business,
you want to think again before you pivot.
A second problem you can run into,
is that even if the results are speaking
to the direction of your firm,
you can get false positives, and
you can get false negatives.
Right, so a false positive,
is where you think you did a good job, but
it actually it's the thing you did is a
bad thing, you just got a false positive.
And a false negative is where,
what you are doing is a good idea, but
your results are saying it was a bad idea,
that's a false negative.
Now what's better,
a false negative or a false positive?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah,
everybody loves false negatives better,
because that means you're right.
But here is the problem.
False positives are self correcting.
False negatives are not.
because if I get a false negative,
I'll pivot.
And I won't realize I was right.
A false positive,
I'm going to do it again, and
then I'm going to find out hold on
[LAUGH], turns out that was not correct.
So you actually get a larger sample,
the great professor March,
some of you had when you were here, has an
article on the issue the young man raised.
People don't read the articles so
much, they should.
They definitely read the title.
Learning from samples of one or fewer.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Don't you wish you had written
the paper with that title.
Even if, you know what I mean?
And, that's exactly what happens with
a false negative, is you say, my gosh,
I've done that and boy you should
see what happened, I'm pivoting.
And so you want to run the test again,
there's a sense in which we have to try to
get to a sample size that
resembles something decent.
Of course big data companies have massive
amounts of data, and can do that but,
when it comes to strategy, we'll often run
the test just once, and then shy away.
And so we'll come to this gentleman, and
then we'll come to this gentleman, and
I think that then,
we'll probably have to close.
So, yeah, go ahead.
>> Would you explain how,
or even if your theory
would apply to either, the not for profit
sector, or more importantly, government?
>> Sure, yes,
absolutely it applies to both.
This way of looking at
the world does apply to both.
And but what changes, is the criteria for
deciding on success and failure.
That obviously in the examples I've been
giving, I talked a lot about a market.
And I've talked about success and
failure in that market.
And this performance, presumably,
is market performance.
And we talked about companies being
profitable and growing, and so forth.
In the not for profit sector,
experimentation and performance
also have, they do have to have or
there has to be some kind of returns.
But those returns are a function of
the legitimacy of the organization.
So, legitimacy is the currency
of the not for profit world.
And if I consider the activities
of a particular organization to be
especially legitimate and
praiseworthy then funding sources and
people who give grants and
other kinds of support will fall in line.
And that's also true in government.
Legitimacy is the currency in
the public sector generally.
And so, if you think about it,
legitimacy creates a real problem here,
because often, the experiments
that go awry look illegitimate.
And, we often see risk
averseness in the public sector,
precisely because we're worried
about being illegitimate.
And so, public sector leaders also
have to think about creating context
where it's safe to deviate.
Even though it might seem like
that would threaten legitimacy.
And similarly with selection, if we go
through a process of fail, fast and cheap.
And we try different things in the public
sector or in not for profit organizations
and we fail, grant-giving organizations,
other kinds of donors and
funders are going to look and
say, well what's the story here?
We're seeing a high failure rate.
We would like to see a success rate.
And where you're hurting there is,
once again, in your legitimacy.
And the inability to grow comes down to
the fact that when you're busy changing
the world you can have an legitimacy
crisis during this period as well, but
if you can take the same ideas, and
those of you who work in
not-for-profit and public sector
simply translate them into the performance
metrics that are appropriate for you.
Because evolution happens in the not for
profit section too.
Evolution and
discovery is the way of our world.
Sir.
>> Bill Levi, MBA 71.
Good job.
You're great, thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> I propose to all of us that
the greatest business opportunity of our
time is transforming the world's
largest industry from 85% fossil to
100% renewables as quickly as we
prudently and profitably can do that.
Where's the great leadership in the energy
industry, and why are they so slow?
Picking up, time's running out.
>> Well, I applaud that question, and I'm
thrilled to have it be our last question,
because I think it's probably the most
important question we face today.
And I think we need
leadership on many fronts.
A large number of scholars
at the Woods Institute
here are working on leadership
in various sectors.
And our scientists have obviously
led the way, Chris Field and others,
the author if the IPCC reports
over the years on climate change.
But we also have a big push in
Earth sciences and among a number
of the faculty in the business school and
in engineering trying to show the way, but
it is going to require a lot of effort,
a lot of collective effort.
I think we're to the point
we're in this period.
and the difficulty is many of the changes
that we need to make to move to an economy
that allows for
sustainability worldwide are going to,
they're going to be difficult to implement
in the sense that during this period
they're going to create a lot of problems
and difficulties in performance.
It takes a great deal of courage
to execute on ideas like that, and
while we're making progress, we really
are not making progress fast enough.
And for some years, I ran here at
the school an executive program
on this topic, and
we brought in business leaders,
government leaders and leaders from
social movement organizations and
not for profits,
all three in equal numbers.
And the first day it was
always the scientists.
And then the other days of program were
the economists and sociologists and
other people on the business school
talking about what we can do based on.
But I can tell you,
by the end of that first day It
was a pretty sobering message.
And that message remains very sobering.
And you have to remember that the truth
is the truth whether you want
to hear it or not.
And the important part of first changing
the world is first to get your head around
what's true.
And what's true is that we do face
something that is monumental in
terms of a problem when it comes to moving
away from the fossil fuel economy and
the need to deal with climate change.
Now, translating that into action depends
on where you work and as a leader where
you're going to do this, in the public
sector there's some people trying to show
leadership in the private sector many of
our alums are trying to show leadership.
It sounds like this gentleman
is also showing leadership
in his part of the world.
I think faculty and researchers
need to show leadership as well.
When you have a movement across all of
those fronts of people showing leadership
we have an amazing ability as
a species to solve problems,
and come up with greatness in ways
that we never would have expected.
So, I think this is a domain
where my message that,
we're not here to predict the future,
we're here to create the systems that
discover that future is a message
that needs to be heard.
Thank you very much, and
thank you all for coming back.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]